hey guys it is the 12th of May today my
name is Jess MacDonald and you're
watching games what news Assassin's
Creed syndicate is the talk of the town
after its official reveal but if you're
like me in high school and really just
want the cliffnotes here's a summary
previously known as Assassin's Creed
victory syndicate is going to launch
this fall on ps4 Xbox one and PC it will
be taking a slightly different approach
to combat a significantly different
approach to stealth and will feature
hijack of all vehicles and yes in
industrial revolution era London that
means horses and cards players will get
a new Batman a squirrel on chakra
traversing the city the game will not
have multiplayer and the story breakdown
is as follows in 1868 sibling assassins
jacob and evie frye do their best to
overthrow the templars in London and
they form an underground crime syndicate
in the process you'll get to choose
which twin you play and each have their
own skill trees that are bragged have
released a new gameplay trailer for The
Witcher 3 which highlights dynamic
graphics scaling for the Xbox one
version although The Witcher 3 does run
natively on Xbox one at 900p this
dynamic scaling feature apparently
enables the game to hits
1080p in some instances likely when
there's less stuff going on the
developer have said they're still
working to make the game look as good as
possible across the board promising this
dynamic scaling feature will be
available on Xbox one at launch
despite their fast approaching release
date they've said they are quote
fighting for every line of code I guess
that's why we have day 1 patches finally
in news that's probably surprised
absolutely nobody the division has been
delayed until early next year Ubisoft
revealed the new info during their
financial results announcement for the
year ending March 31 they delivered an
outline of games that would be arriving
during the subsequent fiscal year from
April 2015 to March 2016 during which
Ubisoft says the division would be
arriving on Xbox one ps4 and PC during
its fourth quarter so early next year
it's probably worth noting that this one
was originally supposed
come out in 2014 so you probably already
settled yourself in for for wait let me
know down in the comments if you like
the sound of Assassin's Creed syndicate
and why or why not
you can add your GameSpot we've got news
on classic RPG Grandia - coming to Spain
and out which a3 review that is it for
me today as always let me know what you
cared about and I'll see you same time
tomorrow